so picking off that idea of
relationships with people
think I yell we talk about a lot of
things but talking about money is a
sensitive topic and and there's a
question about being able to ask people
for money without imposing or maintain a
sense of authenticity in the
relationship not feeling like it's just
because that other person has money so
as wondering if you could talk to us
maybe about an example of a conversation
you've had with a big donor and how you
maintain that relationship knowing that
that money is the thing that holds that
relationship together I wouldn't say
that money is what holds the
relationship together because then it
would be so targeted on a goal and you
know then the sincerity the the
seriousness about the relationship you
know would be compromised I mean you
really I believe have to be committed to
what you are fundraising for you have to
believe in that so there are certain
things that I would feel very
comfortable raising money for and that's
higher education there are other things
where my passion isn't as strong it's
this interest but I don't feel as
passionate about it as I do about higher
education so you let those relationships
develop and that's the other thing you
know you can't say it takes one visit
and then you have a relationship it
takes much more you know what it takes
to develop a real good friendship really
relationship so you don't focus on money
you'd focus on the person's interests
and you focus on where these interests
may have a counterpart a match at Yale
and so you let it you let it develop
slowly and you know just the other day
because you asked for an example of an
over of a conversation I was meeting
with the president with somebody who for
whom this was the first meeting with
Yale it's not an a Yale alumnus and so I
happen to be there a little earlier than
the president because he was the weather
was terrible and the taxes didn't drive
right and so I happen to be by myself
with his stoner for the first 15 minutes
I say Dorner he's not a donor yet
um and we had you know and I could see
he asked me me that they are you the
development person I said yes I'm from
development and I could see that he had
a certain expectation of what i would do
next and i just talked up a conversation
with him he is an amazingly interesting
person and it was very easy to you know
to to get in engage in a conversation
well afterwards a day later i got
feedback from the fourth person who was
there who came with him and he said you
know he was very pleased to meet both of
us obviously he was very pleased to meet
the president but he also commented that
i was very different from other
fundraisers who always immediately go
toward talking about a gift and in my
view that's not philanthropy that's not
enabling people to do what they want to
do what they can do with their resources
that are for some people are incredibly
big and for others not so big so my role
is to facilitate something but through a
relationship that is truly honest and I
have a role from a rule for myself you
know three strikes and you're out if I
don't if a donor doesn't connect with me
if I'm not able to connect with a donor
then I say it's probably better for the
institution that somebody else steps in